Vande Irwin's boyfriend congratulate her  dancing with a star's wind I'm so  excited I honestly I can't believe that  I'm here 17 year old took home  Mirrorball trophy on Tuesday night and  her boyfriend  Chandler Powell couldn't be more proud  he posted this sweet shot to Instagram  and wrote quote I've never seen anyone  work as hard as you have and it all paid  off three months without taking a single  day off you deserve this  and just before bindi hit the dance  floor he reminded his followers to vote  posting this group shot and check out  that hashtag proud boyfriend Chandler  has been a huge support to bindi  throughout her journey on the show in  September she gushed to et all about it  it's really funny because every night  I'll come home he'll be like okay let's  get the ice let's get a cup of tea and  let's get your food it's kind of this  checklist and I think that that love and  support is just is something that we all  will need in life